you may have used a VPN at school to get
past the internet block or you may have
heard that VPNs are useful when it comes
to party but did you know you can save
hundreds of dollars using a VPN
[Music]
welcome to Horace's a VPN in simple
terms connects your PC tablet or device
to another computer called a server
somewhere on the Internet this enables
you to use that computer's internet
connection and as a result it'll appear
as if you're from the country that a
computer isn't alright that's cool but
how would this help you well here are
some of the most common uses for VPNs
you can bypass Geographic restrictions
when streaming video and audio for
example Netflix is only available in the
US so if you're traveling abroad you can
still watch your Netflix shows you can
protect yourself when using public Wi-Fi
like in coffee shops or hotels and you
can gain anonymity online by hiding your
true location while the Europeans were
created to increase security it is
hardly ever used for that anymore
nowadays the primary uses are to access
blog content or pirate
here are some uncommon uses that you
probably haven't heard of but it could
be useful for you you can actually use a
VPN to access of business or home
network while traveling this allows you
to use local file sharing and access a
remote desktop you can use a VPN to
avoid bandwidth throttling your ISP
usually does this when there is love
network congestion and here's the only
you guys have been waiting for how can
you save money using this well if you're
traveling abroad then ticket prices
actually vary based on geographical
location this is due to the varying
income and interest in the route as a
result if you shop for flight tickets
from other countries you may be able to
save a good amount of money
Air France may give better rates to
French viewers because it is their home
country and you can take advantage of
this by using a French VPN also this
doesn't just apply to international
traveling while the same means on
international traveling would be the
biggest you can also use this for
domestic traveling for example ticket
prices may be cheaper from Kentucky
thank California or
also this is not only user for flight
tickets it can also come in handy when
booking hotels as you guys can see VPS
have several uses and if you're really
creative and you can save some money or
just enjoy faster internet so after
hearing about all the benefits related
to VPS and if you're interested then how
do you get a VPN well you may be able to
use a VPN server from your workplace
create one yourself or even host from
from your own house but those are pretty
uncommon for the vast majority of people
the best way is just to use a VPN from a
website some of the most popular VPN
services are expressvpn Talon bear and
strong VPN these all come with free
trials as well so you can always change
your mind or it can be a bit shady and
just apply for the free trial and use it
to buy a ticket and a counselor right
after if you're interested in any of
them that make sure check out the links
down in description below
they're all good VPNs and have different
uses that they're best at Express VPN
has the best combination of ease of use
and really fast servers they support
torrenting and streaming and coming at a
cheap price Tom Barrett is really good
for casual use like in coffee shops but
it isn't really that great when coming
into streaming or torrenting but there
is a free limit of tier finally strong
VPN isn't the easiest to use but it is
good at torrenting and streaming videos
so if you are interested in and if that
the measure check it out down below
overall VPNs are able to protect your
data and are useful and a handful of
scenarios from providing you with faster
internet and saving you money to much
more shady things like pirating or
streaming but that's pretty much it as
to what VPNs are used for so did I miss
anything important that VPNs are used
for make sure come that down below also
if you guys thought this video yourself
or the major drop a like and consider
subscribing if you like see more videos
just like this one but until then I'm
Ari I'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]